يتسبب بفيضانات عارمه
الامم المتحده تحذر المدنيون في السودان
بخطر
رسميا كريم بنزيما الى الاتحاد السعودي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
خطيره يخلفها وسيخلفها تفجير سد الواقع في
الاجزاء التي تسيطر عليها روسيا من منطقه
خرسون الاوكرانيه وكانت ساسو الروسيه اخذت
بارتفاع منسوب المياه لاكثر من عشره امتار
في نوفاكا ما دفع بالمسؤولين بالمنطقه
للبدء بخطه طوارئ لان حوالي 80 قريه وبلده
وما تتاثر بالدمار الجزئي الذي حدث للسد
وتنغمر بالفيضانات حين تتبادل كييف وموسكو
الاتهامات حول مسؤوليه التفجير
لا احد مستثنى من الخطر في السودان هذا هو
عنوان التحذير الذي اطلقته الامم المتحده
عبر مفوضها لشؤون اللاجئين فيليبوغراندي
الذي عبر عن صدمته بشان مقتل عشره لاجئين
على الاقل في هجوم بالعاصمه الخرطوم
غراندي حذر في حسابه على تويتر من ان جميع
المدنيين الموجودين بالسودان في خطر
بمختلف شرائحهم اما سياسيا فقد اكد قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان في اتصال هاتفي
مع وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اكد ثقته في منبر جده بما يقود
لسلام مستدام بالسودان
دفعت مايكروسوفت 20 مليون دولار لتسويه
اتهامات وجهتها لها لجنه التجاره
الاتحاديه الامريكيه والسبب انها جمعت
معلومات وبيانات شخصيه بطريقه غير قانونيه
عن اطفال مشتركين في نظام اكس بوكس
للالعاب وذلك دون اخذ موافقه الوالدين
بشكل صحيح المتحدث بس مايكروسوفت اوضح ان
الشركه ملتدمه بالامتثال للقرار كما انها
سوف تحل المشكله الفنيه وقالت انها تسببت
بحفظ بيانات الاطفال في النظام فيما يشترط
القانون على الخدمات والمواقع الالكترونيه
الموجهه للاطفال الحصول على موافقه
الوالدين وابلاغهما بشان عمليه جمع
البيانات الشخصيه عن طفلهم
الى عالم الرياضه اذ وقع اتحاد جده مع
الفرنسيه كريم بنزيما مهاجر ريال مدريد
الاسباني عقدا احترافيا ينضم بموجبه
الاخير الى صفوف الفريق في فتره
الانتقالات الصيفيه التي ستنطلق مطلع
الشهر المقبل بنزيما اعلن رحيله عن ريال
مدريد صبيحه المباراه الاخيره في الدوري
الاسباني امام بيلبو يوم الاحد الماضي في
ملعب سانتريكو بنيابيو والتي سجل فيها
هدفه لفريقه وهو الهدف الوحيد فيما امضى
كريم بنزيما 14 عاما في صفوف ريال مدريد
حقق خلالها 25 بطوله
ونقدم النشره من بريطانيا حيث تم بيع
صندوق صيني نادر بمبلغ وصل الى 358 الف
دولار تعود صناعته الى القرن الخامس عشر
اي في عهد الامبراطور الخامس لاسره مينج
تقارير افادت الديانه الصندوق الصغير تم
شرائه في عام
1946 ب19 جنيها استرلينيا فقط اي ما يعادل
24 دولارا ولم يعر انتباه اي احد منذ ذلك
الحين فيما كان من المتوقع ان يتراوح سعره
في مزاد ما بين
7400 واثنى واربع مئه دولار
لكنه تخطى وفي في هذه المساله السعر
المتوقع قبل المزاد العلني